escaping a war zone but still able to
pursue his passion
Gosha staying on the ice was top
priority whether in Kiev or Bristol
now eight months on from fleeing to the
UK he and mother Arena have made the
tough choice to return home we are happy
we enjoy being at home even during this
hard and difficult times
for us exactly this is the right
decision
because Gucci was crying he was
sometimes depressed because he separated
from his father when we arrived
it took us maybe it took me maybe more
than months to adapt because we had so
many changes uh city looked a little bit
depressed
you can feel that war is an heir there
you go and stop cross under push cross
under hold it after appearing on Sky
News dancing on I start Matt Evers
reached out to help the pro training
kept gosh's skills up
now back home constant power Cuts
because of the war been training he's
off to under backup lighting we have uh
you know days without electricity at
home we are in a normal regime now we
train a three five full days per week uh
usually three lessons per day
yeah
Gosha and his mum spent four months
living with their host Caroline one day
they say they hope to return
we would like uh someday yes return like
tourists
to see Caroline I would like to see them
even in Kiev if if we have peace and
they would like to come show me the best
what is his name
despite the relief of being back home
with family the war and worry continues
before this blackout we had another uh
fear I even forgot about this It Was
Fear all the time and risk of nuclear
um disaster
and it just changes all this nightmare
so I hope
soon somehow the missiles will will
finish
it will be a Christmas under conflict
but one that means they're finally back
home
Dan Whitehead Sky News